so stanford recently
announced that they're going back to
virtual
at least for some period of time in
response to the esc maybe you can
clarify but i think it's in response to
the escalated
um how would they phrase it it's related
to omicron
and uh a few other universities are kind
of like
uh considering back and forth in my
perspective
as somebody who loves in person lectures
who
sees the value of that
to students to young minds
also looking at the data
seems
the
[Music]
risk aversion
in university policies around this given
how healthy the student population is
seems
not well calibrated let's put it this
way also pathological pathological is
one way to put it given that i believe
depending on the university but i think
many universities require that the
student body is vaccinated
at this point
so
i think it's a big mistake by stanford
to do this
and um
i i'd like to say that because i just
hope mit doesn't
but what are your thoughts about that is
there is
i completely agree with you i think um
we have
failed in our mission
to educate our students
by these this decision uh and i think i
frankly just more broadly i think we
failed generally over the course of the
last year and a half in living up to our
educational mission
the in-person
teaching is vital
for and now i can understand you have uh
if you have older faculty the the
principle of focus protection says
provide some alternative teaching
arrangements for them
that makes sense to me from the kids
point of view they're more harmed by not
getting the education we promised them
than by than by covid
so applying this principle of this
focused protection
let young professors teach in person
this is before the vaccine after the
vaccine let everyone teach in person
yeah this is the part i don't understand
the discussion we're even having because
um
okay let's leave focus protection aside
here because that's a brilliant policy
for perhaps for the future when there's
no vaccine
now with the vaccine i'm
misunderstanding something here because
we're now in a space
that's
psychological
not it's no longer about biology because
uh with the booster shots which i
believe mit is now requiring before
january
with the booster shots the data shows no
matter how old you are the risks are
very low
for
ending up in a hospital
relative to all the other risks you face
when you're older
i don't i don't understand can you
explain the policy around
closing
a university but also just a
policy about
just being so
scared still
in the university setting i think the
universities the great university has
done great harm
by modeling this kind of behavior yes
that to me decided to keep interrupting
but to me the university should be the
beacon of great behavior
not the beacon of like
scared
conservative
let's not mess up
let's not make it pathological let's not
make anybody angry
let's it should be a place to play in
the space of ideas yes
so i think
the central problem is actually related
to the central problem of covet policy
more generally
the goal seems to be to stop the disease
from spreading
rather than to reduce the harm from the
disease
if the if the goal is to stop disease
and spreading the sad fact is we have no
technology to stop to accomplish that
at this point yes because like it's
already deeply integrated into the human
civilization well i mean it's here
forever right there's a zero survey of
white-tailed deer in the u.s it turns
out 80 of white-tailed deer in the u.s
have coveted antibodies
dogs get it cats get it
there's almost certainly human human
animal transmission of it um
i mean presumably i mean i've heard bats
get it apparently um so so you you have
uh you have a situation where you have
this disease that's here to stay yeah
and it and the vaccines don't stop the
spread of it the lockdowns don't stop
spreading we have no technology to stop
the spread of it
and so we're burning the earth trying to
stop do something that's impossible
rather than
working on what's possible
uh and so like you know like letting
regular college happen that's a great
good universities are a wonderful
invention
and it's contributed so much to society
to decide to shut it down
the universities should be fighting
tooth and nail to not be shut down not
the other way around yeah
whatever the mechanisms that uh results
in the university is doing that that's
probably this is me talking it probably
has to do with certain incentives for
the administration probably has to do
with lawyers and legal kinds of things
to
to avoid uh legal trouble but once again
it's when the administration has too
much power and too much definition of
what the policy is for the university
that's when you get into trouble the
beauty
the power of the university should be
about the faculty and the students
administration
just gets in the way get out of the way
i mean they can help organize things
they they they play some important role
but they they certainly do but they need
to remember what the mission is the
mission is not
safety the mission actually university
should be dangerous places you know for
ideas and
and whatnot
you